so max lovely to see here at the
premiere for they came together tonight
tell me about what you do in the film I
could not be more excited I play Paul
Rudd's younger brother in the movie and
we have some great scenes and I'm kind
of I'm kind of an annoyance to him but
maybe then kind of come around towards
the end and you know and there for him
and we just have a fun brotherly
relationship in the film and it was just
it was probably it's probably most proud
of anything I've ever done bonding with
even said to be honest you know it was
one of those experiences where the whole
cast there were some trailers there was
not and and you know this is not like a
couple guys in the woods shooting a
movie on like hey we have like four
dollars you know it was there's a lot of
big actors in this and there was no
trailers we all hung out the whole time
we were all in this together we all
really understand stood the tone of the
film and we're kind of led by David and
Michael and it was a dream experience
for that for those reasons it compared
making something like they came together
to obviously we know and love you for it
for example in new you go it was just so
different and it was nice to kind of
step out of that and do something else
and it was really interesting for me to
kind of you know you're sorry you're
with the same actors for eight months
and every once in while somebody comes
in but to kind of especially after the
shot this movie after the first season
maneuver
to kind of go from where I was which was
like doing guest stars on CSI to then
having a wonderful year on new girl and
then all of a sudden be thrust into this
position where I'm like with Amy Poehler
and Paul Rudd and it was a great
learning experience for me and just to
be around them and watch them do their
thing and watch them behind the camera
it's just it was great if you learned
from it they're gonna take forward maybe
it's in one you girl or the project I
don't know I think you just absorb so
much from just being around it and you
know watching what Paul does what Amy
does you're like I remember having a lot
of experiences where hey I'd be in
scenes with them and I was just watching
and I all got ahead of line what a
mistake that was but other moments were
just kind of just like whoa watching
these people have done this for a lot
longer than you have and are doing it so
much better than you you're gone
oh man this is it was just very cool to
watch forward to next and you go we're
wrapping up the season right now we
obviously have the Superbowl episode
coming up which is exciting and you know
I'm not really sure what's going on
there's a lot kind of like it's it's all
working itself out I know I'm not really
sure what we're working towards it
because the writers don't tell us either
but yes we I think that'll happen for
sure and finally we've got Veronica Mars
the movie to look forward to as well now
with you in the TV series how's it
compared making the movie two TV series
and what can we expect it was a lot of
it was a lot of fun I was only down
there for for a day but from what I hear
the movie is so much fun and I think
they really made a movie for the fans
I think if you were a fan of the show
you were going to be very happy with the
outcome of the film max it's an Aussie
delivery talking do you have time
tonight so much
you